ciao ragazzi bentornati un nuovo video
oggi voglio farvi vedere come passerò da
questa cosa qui a questo non chiedetemi
perché l'abbia fatto soprattutto non so
che cosa abbiate visto perché ancora non
ho visto il risultato quindi potrebbero
essere un qualcosa di pazzesco visto che
è la prima volta che cerco di farmi un
trucco dalla tranquilla oppure potrei
sembrare la befana partiamo subito a con
questo tutorial che io farò
assolutamente non l'ho mai fatto in vita
mia quindi vi chiedo perdono augurio del
make up tra queen questo qui non è un
modo per prendere assolutamente anzi
credo che l'imitazione sia la forma più
alta di rispetto
poi mi sono preparato ho visto un bel po
di video di drag queen che facevano
tutorial di make up e ho pensato quindi
di unire tutte le conoscenze che mi sono
fatto all'interno di un solo video un
pochino come quando il mio di matech
s'impara kung fu e vedere che cosa esce
fuori parliamo da col primo step che mi
fa un po paura che è quello delle
sopracciglia perché loro se le
cancellano i ne usano la colma che
schifo in tutto questo c'è luigi qualche
tennista piastrato la parrucca del dopo
vado a fare una cosa che per me molto
molto più pesante che mettermi un asti
sette chili non poter vedere quanti ne
ho di make up sulla faccia che è quella
di togliermi la barba vado e toni su
piloti
sbam a me sembra renato zero è un uomo
togliersi la barba un pochino come
salire su una bilancia vorrei dirlo è un
atto di grande coraggio e ti ricorda
anche quanti menti nascondere di sotto
al telo
partiamo subito a quella parte che
preferisco che quella dell'ing alcune
drag utilizzano questo sia per tipo
nascondersi il coso è sembrata avete
capito a farsi un bradipo cliente che
non c'è più niente
cosa che non farò su questo canale
perché è la fars al vento un trucco ma
lo usano anche per fare tipo un lifting
che adesso vi farò vedere
viene piazzato un altro metodo è quello
di lasciarsi tutta la testa c'è massima
stima delle drag queen
credo di aver sbagliato tutto perché ci
sembra il dottor spock in questo momento
temo di aver messo lo scotch troppo
basso però dio mai incollato alla
carriera ok
in questo momento calcolate che le mie
guance sono all'altezza delle mie tempi
e passiamo con la base abbia secondo me
è un tesoro e ciglia impossibile
nasconderlo ma è ragione questo questo
qui ok perfetto sta sbagliando
milano rotto già il voldemort l'olimpia
me la faccio paura c'è da quali credo
pure ma in camere sono mostruoso sono
terrificante nemici né in questo momento
sono due grumi però in camera non si
vede fin toro che vedete sul web si e
scollato tutto se ne vada cosa bella che
non riuscire a vederlo senza cappello la
metterò tutto il trucco assomigliano a
mia madre correttore fanno pure quella
specie di triangolo aspetta e speriamo
che il telefono del triangolo c'è le
droghe diventano delle stragi che a un
certo punto mi sembra che mi sto
travestendo da donna mollato dal marito
ma non è come fare ragazzi ma è un bush
ha definito io in questo momento se fa
dove strada abbaglio i gatti cell e le
macchine se mi vedono passare testata mi
fanno il doppio doppi fari perché
pensano che stia vagliando faccio paura
non capisco come questa cosa possa
diventare alla fine la donna ea questo
punto bisogna fare quella cosa che si
chiama bay king si prende
di cipria e la si mette qua sotto non
credi televoto real facili su internet
un inserviente facili se io mi devo
mettere un pochino di questo li hanno il
naso fanno pure tacco mica semplice
adesso prendiamo questa spugnetta
pensiamo a lista travestendo da zombie
terrifica mamma mia
allora cari mangiamorte cene guancia
scalata che sembra uscita un'altra tomba
l'altra e uscirà una carlo de rio
prendiamo una potere di congiure scalare
dei soli in queste guance nostri menti
rupo sceglierà di sascha wave non mi
sento proprio a mio agio in questo
momento ci sono tipo una tredicenne che
sta sperimentando per la prima volta
quei trucchi mentre si scremano le
sopracciglia
adesso sto facendo questa cosa che si
chiama ma sì sì sì sì a quello che fanno
anche loro
io non capisco se è giusto se è
sbagliato perché ho deciso di fare
questo video continuiamo a scolpire non
lo so qualsiasi cosa a questo punto mi
sento michelangelo c'è un forestiero che
basta basta potrei continuare
all'infinito a cercare di migliorare un
cesso ma non rimarrà un cesso optato per
un trucco naturale ho pensato vorrei
fare una cosa tipo natural chic è bello
portarvi a pezzi le facce le realtà sto
sperando di fare un qualcosa di alta
moda e credo sia cosa qui possa essere
un po diventa scelti dalla scena sciacca
la calata un po black swan categoria min
all'obitorio si è detto che michael
jackson era morto chi sempre questo mi
sembro qualcuno o qualcuna non lo so
senza esagerare
yes baby il trucco si può correggere e
come una tela tu sei l'artista o il
bandalo io qui metto una linea da verso
il fuori
economicamente controllato seguano altre
linee scelsi il fuori sono cugine
secondo me sembrerò cotti po 40 anni in
più cioè niente prima non togliermi le
sopracciglia crearti di boschi e mi
sembrò hashtag stupito così sempre e
comunque in camera sembra meno una
quello che dal vivo pensate quindi che
cosa vedono allo specchio
senti stiamo a fabre ag diamogli cioè
perché se no se noi sta andando in
chiesa così questo pezzo più difficili
tutti allora io ero bisogno sicuramente
un qualcosa di brillante avevi dei green
arrow di glitter o i brillantini stanno
facendo qualcosa bisogna nominare
ragazzi che so che tutti i luglio quindi
illuminiamo qui
perdonatemi mi sto facendo perder tempo
grigio per ha sbattuto del dirigerla
soprattutto se non brillano al completo
che mi dici così gioioso che dice il mio
fallimento
io fu in questo momento mi sono rifatto
le gioverà giglio
lo sto facendo arrivare fino alle tempie
alice mi recherò a questi pannelli
quando iniziai affari chris e mi disse
ti torneranno utili penso mi quando gli
usi decreto scusa lì perché adesso ti
sto pensando che sono mortificato
aspetta aspetta però se io faccio questo
di colpo sembra che sono convinto forse
la porta a casa con un po di
atteggiamento
non è giusto fermarsi non è rispettoso
nei confronti di chi arrivato fino
adesso con che stomaco quindi
leggermente non tanto perché sempre
tante sfumare proprio così la butta in
caciara matita bianca sotto l'occhio
l'occhio perché loro sono gli occhi
rossi rossi son lacrime il ring non e
nient'altro rosa del deserto
anche perché mi sembra che tutto il
resto mi abbia veramente deluso e basta
infatti volete vi aspetta senza sempre
come che fanno una che fanno bere un po
di fix plus
tra queste da che erano ruggine che sono
diventati conoscenti
esse sono storto sisto per farmi sette
paesi sopracciglia sali poi finisci
preparate le troppe dire causa syndrome
io non mi arrendo
cioè se tu pensi io sono nato qui per
tornare a casa in lacrime sbaglia di
grosso chi a casa si sta già malato in
camera non vede solo le sopracciglia il
portale verso c'è poi un po di plus
tutto per sembrare che c'è un po di
colore di un pò sempre olivo ecco che
serve i blush sicilia ci sono le
tagliano le saux tagliare che rimette a
farlo diego della palma presso cui dico
sempre conoscere la teoria non è uguale
saperlo fare e nella grande morale di
oggi adesso faccio la7 non mi posso
andare a mettere in bagno queste razze
torno subito sempre più carico sempre
più stupita ma in vero che il mascara lo
metti per forza a bocca aperta
se mosca non lo metto per proporre al
mese stacchino isole crc da e vediamo di
fare questo questa sciocchezza non
bisogna fare così
alice ha detto bisogna fare così
disegnerà chiuderlo grillo basta dove è
di fronte perché guardate al macho le
ciglia finte come daniela che era
perfetto messo un piccolo puntino
l'illuminante sulla stavo mettendo un
pochino di alluminio
sopra si sbatta di un altro ovunque
ormai lo stomaco più sfumando può far
mascherone adesso da mirabilandia una
casa dell'orrore dove lavoro no non c'è
più
le labbra faccio cioè faccio un bel
pandoro due omoni ora sta rischiando
grassi crown non solo in forma di a
breve sono quattro sì ci stava un
sofisticato cava non so chi sembra ma
comunque mi dispiace per a persona
lavora assoluti tutto e adesso giusto
perché rimaniamo semplici un po di gloss
o sbagliato da floccari ci mettiamo
tutto entra nella nostra vita
by luca ho messo tutto tornò subito con
la parrucca mamma è un ex 34 rock hard
mamma
questo è il risultato con diciamo una
parrucca gentilmente piastra da da lui
ti posso dire una cosa non lo so seconda
dell'angolazione sembra qualcosa di
diverso un po martina pinto sotto sotto
steroidi
vabbè che tiene ragazzi io stavo già
subirà pane una delle corse questi
trucchi da drive sono fatti per essere
stupiti ecco qua ci sembra una di loro
non credo che dire ragazzi io vi chiedo
scusa ma allo stesso tempo vi ringrazio
se siete riusciti a vedere questo video
fino a questo momento e che tiene alla
prossima a il mio nome non esisti ca no
il mio norme e di jacqueline
sechin salari noi c'è un nome con il
cuore che è sheila williams è l'opposto
del mio nome ho capito un bacio del sì
la se preferite da klimt salari oppure
potrei chiamare me tipo quad katrina
tipo couture ragazzi c'è lucenti netti
[Risate]
ma stromboli temi ipnotico bella ragazzi
che disco bella ragazza mi scattò a
dormire mani non ho mangiato
oddio ottima dieta truccarsi lavoro anzi
stava ragionando su una cosa fatemi
sapere quali potrebbe essere un buon
nome da drag perché jacqueline salari e
veramente una sheila williams
e è troppo tennista sono indecisa